[Aplausos]
gracias mar por la presentación me
escuchan
hola buenas tardes mi nombre es jennifer
espinoza
yo soy una bióloga y antes que todo
quiero decirles que yo siempre he creído
que uno de los roles principales de la
ciencia es justamente generar
conocimiento pero no conocimiento vano
sino para llegar a impactar de manera
positiva a la sociedad
permítanme empezar con una pequeña
experiencia hace muchos años cuando era
niña
he enfermado todo eso alguna vez nos
hemos informado cierto y en particular
me informaba bastante y mis padres me
llevaban al hospital lleva al hospital y
algo que me asombraba tremendamente y
obviamente fascinado de todo el tiempo
que tenía que esperar para que el médico
me atienda y otra cosa que me sorprende
aún más era que cuando salía había aún
mucho más gente que seguía esperando a
ser atendidos
esto obviamente a un niño le incomoda
bastante aburre tetera
sin embargo ahí no acaba la cosa
habían ocasiones en las que yo tenía que
regresar para hacerme análisis y
regresar nuevamente después para que
finalmente me digan qué cosa es lo que
teníamos y es que llegaban a poder
terminarlo
años después yo decidí a estudiar
biología
mediante la biología pude conocer a
fondo diferentes aspectos de los seres
vivos como por ejemplo las enfermedades
nos atacaban como nuestro cuerpo
reaccionaba ante ello y es así que
decidí especializarme en biología
molecular
sí
bien luego de mis estudios en biología
molecular hacia investigaciones etcétera
y de alguna forma poco a poco y en
realidad sin querer fui teniendo visitas
a los hospitales y qué cosas creen que
es lo que vi exactamente lo que había
ocurrido hace casi 20 años atrás
[Música]
grandes cantidades de personas esperando
a ser atendidos oa ser diagnosticados en
un hospital
es ahí en donde comencé a entender bueno
está bien existen enfermedades pero
estas enfermedades no son todas iguales
algunas necesitan tratamientos y
diagnósticos mucho más complejos que los
hacen más caros ya que puede necesitar
equipos o también personal altamente
capacitados
todos hemos escuchado acerca de test
diagnóstico cierto un test diagnóstico
conocido es el test de elisa que en
realidad entre otras cosas diagnóstica o
detecta la presencia de un virus llamado
hb no solamente sirve para eso puede
decir es una técnica que nos permite
diagnosticar diferentes enfermedades
pero por eso es conocido otro test por
ejemplo es cuando nos hacen el test del
aliento para poder detectar la presencia
de esta bacteria llamada 'helicobacter
pylori' 'helicobacter pylori' permite
diagnosticar por ejemplo úlceras
gástricas que pueden desarrollar más
adelante de casos de cáncer
sin embargo muchos de estos tipos de
diagnóstico están basados en una
molécula que reconoce esta molécula
del colegio
esta molécula se llama anticuerpo y
todos hemos escuchado algunas de los
anticuerpos los anticuerpos en realidad
son parte de nuestro mecanismo de
defensa son parte del sistema inmune que
justamente van a defendernos de
diferentes patógenos como bacterias
virus entre otros
bien como si estos anticuerpos son
capaces de poder identificar estos
patógenos como virus y bacterias porque
son capaces de unirse muy
específicamente a estos a estos agentes
infecciosos
entonces yo puedo desarrollar diferentes
diagnósticos basados en esta molécula
llamada anticuerpo es decir que si yo
voy a un laboratorio
puedo producir diferentes tipos de
diagnóstico para enfermedades distintas
eso no es del todo cierto porque si yo
quiero producir este tipo de moléculas
me toma bastante tiempo es un proceso
bastante caro este tipo de moléculas son
[Música]
sensibles a la temperatura qué quiere
decir eso que se puede malograr si es
que yo las expongo a temperaturas muy
altas y además su producción en masa es
bastante dificultosa
este anticuerpo de aquí el que acabamos
de ver es un anticuerpo humano como el
que tenemos todos y en realidad la
mayoría de vertebrados tenemos un
anticuerpo similar los conejos los
ratones inclusive las aves
pero ocurre algo particular con las
alpacas las alpacas producen un
anticuerpo especial llamado anticuerpo
de cadena pesada y el pse anticuerpo de
cadena pesada fue descubierto a pesar de
que se presente en las alpacas fue
descubierto nada menos que en bélgica
cuando un profesor y sus alumnos durante
una clase práctica de bioquímica
analizaba en la sangre de un dromedario
descubrieron unos anticuerpos extraños a
los que llamaron anticuerpos de cadena
pesado de llamamos de simple forma
anticuerpos especiales poco después se
descubrió que no solamente estaban
presentes en dromedario sino en toda la
familia de camélidos que incluye por
ejemplo a camellos también al para
llamas y alpacas
alpacas que hemos tenido desde hace
miles de años presentes en nuestro país
de este tipo de molécula de anticuerpo
especial producido por los camélidos yo
puedo generar algo llamado nano cuerpo y
el nano cuerpo como bien dice su nombre
es una molécula muy pequeña es 10 veces
más pequeño que un anticuerpo
convencional además puede soportar altas
temperaturas que era algo que no me
permitía ser por ejemplo un anticuerpo
normal también son muy fáciles de
producir puedo producirlos en
microorganismos y tienen un bajo costo
todas estas ventajas y sigo manteniendo
la detección de enfermedades mediante
este nano cuerpo
ok yo sé que los diagnósticos podían
hacerse con anticuerpos también puedo
hacerlo con nano cuerpos entonces si
tienen las mismas propiedades y en donde
voy a producir bueno en realidad estos
anna no cuerpos no son producidos en una
fábrica común esta es mi fábrica de
producción de nano cuerpos
[Música]
yo voy a hacer que la alpaca produzca
enano cuerpos específicos a enfermedades
perdón a patógenos como virus bacterias
que yo desee
porque el aipac a ustedes saben más o
menos cuántos alpacas hay en el perú
son más de 3 millones de alpacas en el
perú que se encuentran principalmente en
ciudades como puno huancavelica ayacucho
etcétera
bien entonces la tenemos bastante
disponibles y además estamos
aprovechando un recurso peruano
cómo es que yo logro poder hacer
producir estos nano cuerpos a estas
alpacas lo que yo hago es una especie de
vacunación a estos animales es el cuerpo
de estos animales aprenden a producir
estas moléculas ante un patógeno que yo
he escogido ante cualquier virus ante
cualquier bacteria luego mediante
técnicas de biología molecular yo voy a
hacer y voy a modificar el adn de una
bacteria para que estas pequeñas
bacterias produzcan en grandes
cantidades
estos nano cuerpos
no se preocupen estos son los cuerpos
que tenemos en el perdón a estas son las
alpacas que tenemos en la universidad
como pueden ver están bastante
saludables así que todo él nunca en
realidad logra que estar saludables
durante todo el proceso y después
siempre están acompañadas de un médico
veterinario y también en condiciones
óptimas
bien
hemos hablado de anticuerpos de nano
cuerpos técnicas diagnósticos pero como
así estas alpacas se logran relacionar
con el cáncer es que si como carne de
alpaca me voy a curar el cáncer en
realidad no
el cáncer es una enfermedad bastante
compleja tiene diferentes causas no
tiene solamente una pero hay agentes
infecciosos que pueden llegar a causar
cáncer uno de ellos es este virus es un
virus de la hepatitis este virus de la
hepatitis b es uno de los causantes del
cáncer hepático y actualmente más de 250
millones de personas se encuentran
infectadas con este virus y por lo tanto
susceptibles a desarrollar cáncer
otro virus que puede producir cáncer es
el cáncer el virus del papiloma humano
este virus de papiloma humano es el
principal causante de cáncer de cuello
uterino causa alrededor del 90% de casos
de cáncer y aquí cada año hay 500.000
nuevos casos de infecciones con este
virus en mujeres es más se dice que
cerca del 80 por ciento de mujeres va a
infectarse con algún tipo de este virus
durante toda su vida
bien ambos ambos virus y ambos patógenos
son totalmente prevenibles existen
vacunas cierto existen vacunaciones sin
embargo a pesar de eso causan más de un
millón de muertes cada año en todo el
mundo entonces a quien hace la pregunta
yo puedo detectar estos patógenos estos
virus antes de que sea muy tarde antes
de que desarrolle el cáncer en sí la
respuesta es sí
y eso es lo que nosotros hemos estado
trabajando en realidad hemos estado
desarrollando una tecnología en la cual
funciona como una tira reactiva como una
prueba de embarazo en la cual yo utilizo
estos nano cuerpos específicos que van a
detectar de manera temprana la presencia
o ausencia de estos virus con una sola
muestra obteniendo mis resultados en tan
solo minutos
porque esto es importante
esto es importante porque son mucho más
accesibles y mucho más rápidos no
necesitan ni personal ni equipos
especializados puede llegar a
poblaciones muy vulnerables sin
necesidad de transportarlos en cadena de
frío o algo similar
además su costo es mucho más bajo que
los métodos convencionales
imagínense si tan solo hubiésemos podido
prevenir el 10 por ciento de ese millón
de muertes haciendo este diagnóstico de
manera temprana habríamos salvado
100.000 vidas
bien sin embargo esta tecnología es
mucho más poderosa
puedo salvar miles de vidas
diagnosticando los tiempos y de manera
temprana sin embargo también me permite
visualizar células tumorales en
desarrollo en individuos vivos como este
caso de aquí estoy visualizando tres
células tumorales de cáncer de mama para
que puedan ser encontradas y luego
escindidas de manera correcta y temprana
esto funciona también con en seres vivos
o sea que se mantienen vivos durante
este tipo de experimentos y las toman y
luego las toma es un tipo de cáncer
digamos a grandes rasgos es un tumor
cerebral y este tumor cerebral tiene un
crecimiento bastante rápido y agresivo
sin embargo otros estudios también han
descubierto que si yo trato estas
personas a estos a estos animales con
glioblastoma
con estos nano cuerpos puedo detener el
crecimiento de las células cancerosas y
además inhibir su invasión hacia otros
tejidos
no sólo eso imagínense que yo puedo
utilizar a estos nano cuerpos como un
transportador de drogas o medicamentos
para que vayan dirigida a mente hacia
los tejidos cancerosos y no se vayan al
cielos tejidos sanos causando daño
colateral en un ser humano
ahora todos estos resultados nos pueden
sonar de alguna forma
bastante buenos sin embargo estos
todavía son estudios y necesitan
realizarse muchos más para que lleguen a
ser aplicados a los seres humanos
la organización mundial de la salud
estima que cada año se diagnostican 14
millones de casos de personas con cáncer
este número para el 2030 va a alcanzar
los 21 millones al año
nosotros podemos prevenirlo con este
tipo de diagnóstico temprano
la historia con los nueve cuerpos empezó
hace unos 25 años
sin embargo fue un evento totalmente
azaroso nosotros como científicos
tenemos el deber de saber reconocer y
entender las aplicaciones y ventajas que
nos da la naturaleza para poderse poder
desarrollar nuevos métodos que logren
impactar y sacar provecho para la
humanidad
este es el grupo de científicos o parte
del grupo de científicos que trabaja en
el laboratorio
y solo les quiero dejar un mensaje que
cada vez que vean una alpaca desde ahora
no solamente vean a una parte de de la
fauna peruana sino también una gran
aliada para el cáncer gracias
[Aplausos]